- I grew up drinking Slushies.
- Feel like a lot of Slushie
flavors are made up flavors.
Like Blue Raspberry does not exist.
(upbeat music)
I can't find it.
- I feel like I'm at a winery, except just
less expensive and classy.
(laughing)
- I feel like a child.
- It's kinda good.
- It is good.
- There was a little sourness.
- It's mainly Coke with a fruity blend.
- Lemonade and Coke.
(ding)
(giggling)
- I think it's Coke and Blue Raspberry.
(buzzer)
- It's Coke and Watermelon Sour.
- I go with that.
(buzzer)
- I wish I had something
to clear my palette,
but it's okay.
- [guy] Got any coffee beans?
- That's sour!
That's like a Jolly Rancher in a Slurpee.
- Blue Raspberry seems pretty,
- But wouldn't we see
- [girl] but there's not,
I know!
- [guy] some blue in there?
- But sometimes they say Blue Raspberry
- And then it's red.
- I feel like it must
be a Watermelon Cherry.
(ding)
- I'm gonna go with Cherry and Watermelon.
- I'm gonna go with that too.
(ding)
- Our final answer is Sour
Watermelon and Cherry.
- Watermelon
(ding)
- Before I taste it I'm gonna
guess it's Dirt, Sewage.
- If like Tootsie Roll was a flavor
I would guess Tootsie Roll.
- I don't think Coke is here
and I don't think banana is in here.
- Pina Coloda I don't taste at all.
Cherry I taste a little bit.
- You got any coconut in there?
- (giggling) We're taking
this way too seriously.
- No we're not.
- Coke, Watermelon, Cherry,
- [girl] Yep, I'll approve.
I'll let you say Banana.
- [guy] Lemonada, Banana.
- Sure.
(buzzer)
- Blue Raspberry,
Banana, Watermelon, Coke,
what's the last one?
- I think Pina Coloda.
- Alright, I'll go with you.
(buzzer)
- Watermelon Sour, Pina
Coloda, Banana, Coke,
- And I'm spilling on myself.
- [guy in grey] and lemonade.
- It's Lemonade.
- Wait, did we say that already?
- (laughing) You said Lemonade twice.
You said it twice.
(buzzer)
- Alright, alright.
(upbeat music)
- No!
- What?
- I knew it!
- [tall girl] No you didn't.
(both laughing)
No you didn't
or you woulda said it.